انتهت معجزات الايام الاولى انقضت
المفاجات وبقيت السيئه منها ترتد فيهازات
تتجاوز 400 في اليوم بقيت ظلمه الركام
والحصيله القاسيه والا تزال غير نهائيه
حتى اليوم الثاني عشر وذلك بعد اضافه
منطقه تركيه جديده الى قائمه النكبه وفي
ظل التشارك سوريا وتركيا مصيرا النكبه
ذاتها وكثيره هي المفارقات بين الانساني
والسياسي في المنكوبتين من الكارثه الجنوب
التركي احتضن العالم ماساته بالدبلوماسيه
والاستجابه التضامنيه
7500 عامل اغاثه من 64 دوله ضمن عروض
انطلقتها تركيا من مجموع اكثر من 90 بلدا
ابدى استعدادا للنجده والاكثر حاجه للنجده
الشمال السوري حبيس معاناه تقسيماته
الجغرافيه وانقساماته السياسيه والولائيه
خذله العالم باقرار اممي لعنا في الموت
لسوريين لا زالوا تحت الانقاذ ربما كانوا
احياء حين توقفت عمليات البحث عنهم قصرا
لعدم توفر اللازم لاضافتهم يقدر المرصد
السوري عددهم بالفين على الاقل
نقسم لكم اننا عملنا وبزلنا قصار جهدنا
ان عملياتنا باتت مسار البحث الان
والانتشار
ان الفرص العالقين تحت الانقاض في البقاء
على قيد الحياه نادره جدا
والا تتاخر كثيرا عن موعدها الاحياء
الناجون من الزلزال حتى الان يلاحقهم
الموت بالجوع والبرد بالانتظار الطويل
الكثير منه والقليل من الاستجابه وسنعود
الى المعاناه السوريه واهوالها لكن سنذهب
اولا الى قواسم مشتركه في كارثه لم تفرق
اثرها الحدود اولها الصدمه وبتلاشيها
تتكشف ارقام مروعه لواقع جديده في البلدين
سته وعشرون مليون متضرر على الرقعه
المنكوبه 15 مليونا في تركيا واحد عشر
مليون متضرر في سوريا ومتضرر يعني في
العراء او باحسن الاحوال في خيام او ملاجئ
وضع مؤقت للاطراك دائما غالبا للسوريين
رغم ذلك وضعت منظمه الصحه العالميه هذه
الارقام وهي ترجح ارتفاعها في سوريا التي
خلفت الزلزال فيها اكثر من 12
المصاب في الشمال وهم في امس الحاجه
للعلاج الغداء وبعدها المسكن المفقود
هؤلاء اعشار كارثه حرمت اليوم خمسه ملايين
ونصف المليون شخص من اسقف وجدران تاويهم
من برد الشتاء القارص ومن بينهم نحو 350
الف مسن ونحن مليون ونصف المليون طفل في
جنوب تركيا ومقاطعاتها المنكوبه بعد
الانهيار ياتي الهدم لمدن المتداعيه 25
الف مبنى على الاقل بحسب وزير التخطيط
العمرانيه التركي مراد كروم سيتم هدمه
غازي عنتاب مركز الزلزال الاول قررت
السلطات هدم بلدات فيها وعلى راسها نوردا
واصلاحيه مجموع المباني التي سار عليها
القرار يتجاوز 8000 مبنى سكانها مشاهدينا
نصف مليون شخص ربع سكان الولايه
القرار ذاته اتخذ في كهرمان مرعش ليمحى
اثر بازرجيك هو البستان مركز الزلزال
الثاني بهدم ما تبقى من مباني صامده لعدم
صلاحيه العيش فيها